could you tell us your exact game day
routine I get there around like 1 32 so
I can eat lunch because I'm not hungry
when I pitch I gotta eat early normally
their lineup has come by then I've
already done all the scouting but I'll
go make sure that there's no guys that
aren't playing that are playing or
something like that once I feel good
about how I'm gonna get guys out the one
thing that I've always done is I throw
this ball against the wall is that just
getting a fill yeah you can't just go
out there and rip a thousand curve balls
a day you know but to flip curveballs
against the wall one hop them like you
can do that all day do you do sliders
like that yeah I do every pitch four
o'clock I take a nap all right four
o'clock yes I got my cleats on I'm on
the training table I'm lying down
everybody's tiptoeing through the
clubhouse and then at five o'clock you
have your meeting a little meeting that
takes like 10 minutes max and then I'll
go down the weight room and warm up 558
heat packs 623 and go out on the field 6
40 play catch at home finish before the
anthem so 6 57 finish warming up and
then 708 and go out of the fuel